each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
carnegie
yeah i work as you talking about okay so
first of all I just wanted to put a
picture of University of Victoria
because it's a pretty nice place and
it's relatively near here so if any time
you any of you want to visit just drop
me an email and can work something out
so overview this is a quick overview of
my talk I'm going to cover very quickly
a little bit of my background which
cormac already mentioned and then talk
about why music is interesting both from
a perspective of interest in terms of
users and and also from a more kind of
scientific perspective or research
perspective and then the main bulk of my
talk is going to be on content based
music analysis a little bit about future
challenges and then in the end I was
just very very quickly do a snapshot
overview of what I'm currently doing at
uvic so my background I did my PhD at
Princeton with very kool Kone music and
all your retrieval I did a boss look at
CMU with Roger dannenberg and I also
worked with in for media group that does
a lot of some of you might know a lot of
video in audio retrieval and I've done
some consulting on or audio
fingerprinting for me logic and
real-time music speech classification
for all musical company called old music
that's in the Netherlands Oh someone I
would never expect to be here okay so
why music music is this is a relatively
loaded slide with pictures that it's
kind of fun what I want to convey with
this slide is that music is a global
thing it has been with humanity since
ancient times these are big ten thousand
before Christ prehistoric flutes ancient
Egyptian musicians so pretty much there
is no culture in the
world that doesn't have music and it's
pervasive and it's very very diverse and
it's definitely something interesting I
mean if we think about it the fact that
we listen to organized collections of
air vibrations and somehow find them
fascinating enough to spend so much time
listening to that is a very bizarre
thing in some ways but it's definitely
very pervasive so music today I'm sorry
I have to go with itunes but they are
sort of with what they are so itunes
recently reached 100 million urges songs
so that's at least an indication that we
got music purchasing in the digital
domain can work so and you can fit 10
thousands on in an ipod sixty or eighty
percent of isp bandwidth and that's an
anecdotal kind of statistic is taken by
people transferring legal and illegal
mp3 files so it's a it's a big thing
another indication that it's a big thing
is that the whole dispute between the
European Union and Microsoft was about
the inclusion or not the inclusion of
the media player it wasn't they didn't
care about minesweeper or the calculator
they cared about you know the media
player so it is really important music
is an important part people use
computers a lot to listen to music these
days and one just as a note even our
imagination and sort of our science
fiction vision of the future includes
music in some way so if you have a cow
singing
for those of you who know this movie for
the interns but don't know this movie i
highly recommend you to find out what
this is watch it here's another example
so anyway so what we imagined could be
the artificial intelligence if you want
of the future at least what artists
imagined that the intelligence of the
future is has a very strong musical
component so music is so the real reason
now why I actually do music research is
that it's more fun than other types of
multimedia analysis and retrieval it has
a large user base and mainly the main
thing is I'm never tired of listening to
music I like so I have I come from a
background from image and video
processing and if any of you have done
work in that area you probably recognize
these two images a lot of conference
papers include those images now we might
be wondering like modeling all brightest
there that's one of the tasks and track
video retriever so personally I prefer
to listen to Miles Davis time
researching and you know 60 hours of
audio about the cliffs were mentally no
dry distorted so that's just a personal
preference so anyway the not so far
future of music retrieval is the way I
see it is you will have a library of all
recorded music everything ever produced
everything everything that is exists on
the planet will be in a small device
that you will be able to listen to so
the main that the name of the game is
how can you search organize classify
retrieve browse how can you deal with
all that information and interesting
ways and I have some examples of things
that I would like to be able to do I
would like to be able to say okay here i
love that it's joplin as a singer
unfortunately she's dead is there any
singer out there that sounds like sure
that I don't know about I'm a saxophone
player so I'm really interested in
saxophone solos so I have all the
recordings of Charlie Parker playing
saxophone and I want to say to my
computer only play me the parts of the
recording work he is so low
and somehow the computer has to know
when there is a saxophone solo which is
a pretty hard thing to do maybe I've
never heard of African music I listen to
the radio I hear a piece of African
music I submitted to some kind of search
engine I find out what music it is just
by sort of the sound of it and then I
figured out is great African music so
that type of application is the goal I
plan for the future now a more one thing
that if you observe popularity
distributions of music you will observe
that there are a few artists that and
some of their qualities have to do more
with their bodies and their appearance
than with their music that are extremely
popular and a lot of other artists that
I as a musician respect enormously and I
feel that they are extreme individuals
and human beings that have tons to offer
that are not well known and I'm not
going to go i don't believe that they're
not as popular because they don't
deserve to be popular it says that they
are not known so my personal agenda is
to try to make the number of new the
number of pieces of music the average
individual listens to more diverse more
personalized more subjective and
essentially make people more aware of
all this large universe of music that in
many ways is unknown so that's my little
personal agenda which is slightly
different than probably what Sony or am
I would do if they were doing music
retriever so now i'm done with this sort
of motivation slides and i'm going to go
into the main part of my talk which is
content-based music analysis so to start
this process i'm going to start with a
little bit of a demo so this is a
essentially content-based music
information retrieval so i'm not going
to talk about how it's done the idea is
that you give it a piece of music there
is no metadata used at all so all the
computer
has is the actual audio over the music
there is no artist no genre nothing used
in metadata and what you do is you pose
a query and you get results so I can't
play all this example so I I what I
decided to do the sample the audience so
i'll start with Cormac and he can pick
one of those queries I'll play it Oprah
ok so this isn't a collection of just to
give you an idea it's a collection of
3500 clips now it's a big story why it's
hard to get a standardized collection so
this is my own personal little
collection of music that I use there's
no Kenny G but it's quite diverse it's
not necessarily a you know
representative of the universal music
but it does have a lot of different
stuff and some indication is all that
stuff I have a square so here's the
query
and here are the results
so it's 37 second clips that were
returned all of them there are pretty
good matches any other one volunteers to
pick one okay so here is world and care
of the results now you notice that they
are really from the same group and
actually that's because these are really
good examples because i'm giving a talk
and I'm sort of demoing the system I
also picked up relatively popular things
so that you know I would have a high
probability that someone in the audience
would know them but again the system
doesn't know anything as far as the
system is concerned they are all 30
second clips there is no information
about album or John I want to emphasize
that any other volunteers I'll do one
more rock okay this is a good one
wait and care of the results
so again you know it's arguable how good
it is but definitely in a collection of
3,000 thing clips it's doing something
so then what I want to show you is a
little bit in a way even more revealing
than when it does really work really
well is what it does when it doesn't
work so well so here are some
interesting queries and I would let's
see anyone volunteering I have to do the
art rock okay okay so this is the this
is the query clip
ok and this out of the results return
so this is um so again you know this is
not perfect if you really hear those
carefully you can and you kind of know
what's happening you can see why it does
it I mean it doesn't have much knowledge
of music it's using some surface
features I will do two more of those any
other volunteers what klezmer okay
here's another
you
so again you know I what I'm trying to
get is maybe some of those matches are
not that good and some of it has to do
just with the fact that there are no
good examples of matches in that space
of 3,000 songs so it kind of tries to
figure out here's a even more
interesting one well this one I really
actively tried to find something I
thought you will really have a hard time
so this is a query
and this is the result so it's so here's
another one that might actually well no
you do actually it's it's funny but
similarity if you do good similarity it
scales well because it's more likely in
a large collection you will find
something very similar what happens
though is you get too many matches that
our route so similar but they are kind
of trivial they become relatively boring
so then you need to basically have and
that's an interesting issue is that
there's this little area where it's
interesting and then if it's too good it
becomes a little bit too trivial so you
have to have a knob to adjust that but
actually it does it does feel relatively
well anytime I increase my database I
you know to really evaluate it and I
will come into that you have to do user
studies very expensively and it's a big
thing to do that but I'm important you
know from my own perception it does
improve as you increase the size i'll
just do one final one for my friend Andy
slots who likes work music in coolin and
african music so this is an interesting
one
so this is a query and the result is
surprising but not so surprising
the point is to focus on the rhythm
rather than the actual texture and I
will get into that so if you want in
this little search you have seen the
influence from African music to sort of
Cuban Latin to jazz and not to get too
much credit for that but anyway so the
interesting part you know all of you
here are familiar with the basics of you
know featured spaces and machinery and
so this is the simple nearest neighbor
type of searching and returning a ranked
list so if you have some representation
here is your query you just look for the
closest matches in some space so the
name of the game is however can we come
up with the right features to represent
music so that's what I'm going to talk
about there are three types of features
that I have worked on they are not
necessarily a full set there are other
things you could take into account
they'll be great one set is essentially
for those of you familiar with speech
recognition just general kind of
spectral features having to do with
essentially the texture of the sound
sort of what instruments are playing how
bright it is how frequently it changes
it's a very similar idea to texture in
images and it's a kind of a similar an
ocean then there is this dividing line
and actually I could sort of arguably I
could take credit for being one of the
few people that have a proposed that is
music specific features so things like
Mel frequency capture all coefficients
work really well in speech recognition
there nothing new things like deed
histogram features which represent the
rhythm of the song have nothing to do
with other types of audio signal only
work for music so it's interesting to
incorporate a little bit musical aspects
into your future feature representation
so quickly about Tim Brown texture it's
exactly the sort of what
said if you're listening to a radio in
the background washing the dishes in
your kitchen and there's a change from
Mozart to Metallica instead of have this
very low attention very washed out sound
but you can tell that change that's
about what you try to model with timbrel
texture so you want to differentiate
mixtures of sound possibly with the same
sort of rhythm or fetch content but with
different instruments playing with a
different kind of feeling so again in
analogy to visual textures sort of it's
a statistical property of the thing how
it evolves so quickly all of you are
familiar one way or another either from
signal processing or from just playing
mp3's for a spectrum display so if you
kind of a spectrum that shows how a
signal is decomposed into different
frequency bands then you can essentially
use that shape as your descriptor there
are a couple of different ways you can
do it i'm not going to go into details
but essentially they all walk down to
reducing the shape of the spectrum into
four or five numbers so what you do is
you take your spectrum you calculate
these numbers for example one would be
the centroid which is essentially if you
try to balance the spectrum on your
finger the frequency where the energy on
the left and the energy on the right is
the same and that's a correlative
brightness then you take that as your
feature representation so that's a
simple spectral description how can you
calculate the spectrum the most common
technique is a short-time fourier
transform so you express your signal
acid your building block is essentially
a sine wave sign weight you can control
their frequency their amplitude so one
way to view this is as you pass your
signal through these very narrow band
filters each each filter outputs and
amplitude in a frequency and then you
could just use those amplitude
frequencies and drive a set of
oscillators and sum them up and recreate
your signal so essentially your spectrum
is really these amplitudes of each
frequency basically this representation
right here another view of the same
processes that you take your signal you
cut it into overlapping segments and for
each of those segments you calculate the
short time that a short-time fourier
transform and calculate the time varying
spectrum that changes over time and for
each of those spectra you calculate your
features so by doing that process you
have essentially a trajectory will
feature vectors over time that represent
how the music changes over time in terms
of texture a more recent technique is
wavelets so one thing that happens is if
you do the short-time fourier transform
you essentially have to choose a certain
time resolution which is kind of large
those sine waves are going to be in
terms of time so if you view this as a
time-frequency plane where time is this
axis and frequencies this X is
essentially your building blocks can be
viewed as these rectangles so note that
in reality they can they're more like
little Hills but you know in terms of if
you just look at their standard
deviation their standard deviation forms
this rectangle and there is the
Heisenberg is uncertainty which tells
you that the area of that rectangle has
to be constant so I can squeeze these
rectangles and make them make my
algorithm be very sensitive to time
events and detect time events very
accurately but then I lose frequency
resolution I don't know what frequencies
are playing if I want to have good
frequency resolution then I need to use
a lot of time and then I lose you know
when things happen so only the extreme
case if you take a bit oven symphony it
could analyze every note very easily if
you take the whole symphony but you
wouldn't know when any of the note was
played if you take a very short slice
you would know when it was everything
was happening but you wouldn't know the
exact frequency so you can't get away
from that uncertainty but you can kind
of play around it and that's what
wavelets do so what you do is for low
frequencies you use a lot of times
you see you have this big start
rectangle but you have good frequency
resolution because this size is
relatively small for high frequencies
you know exactly when they happen but
you don't know the exact frequency so
you traded off one way now why is that
irrelevant is that it turns out that our
ears in our perceptual systems although
not as you know neatly mathematically as
this model are more close to this model
than to a Fourier analysis so both of
these are useful to have and I will also
talk a little bit more about wavelets
for it in the detection a filter bank
view of the same approach is that if you
usually a standard process in signal
processing you want to kind of observe
the behavior of the system as you just
feed it an impulse response if you feed
an impulse response to essentially a
linear filter bank so the short-time
fourier transform can be viewed as the
linear filter bank the output of each
band will be the same duration signal
with different frequencies or fire
frequency will have more Wiggles or less
Wiggles but the output will be sort of
the same duration in contrast the output
of the wavelet transform is the same
shape that scaled down each time so this
shape I am not very good at drawing so
the shapes look a little bit crappy but
really think about each of these are
just a scale version of the other and if
you view it as a spectrum essentially
you have a narrow spectrum here and then
you're you could think of this as a
Fourier transform and you are summing
all the bins here you some a narrow
range of bins then you open it up then
you open it up so so one thing that's
interesting for those of you for
actually this is a good question to ask
you right now how many of you have some
experience with playing a music
instrument in reading music notation
just oh wow really impressive good very
good so I will be able to talk about
some things that usually are hard to
explain that's that's very impressive I
goodnight okay so so if you think of a
piano the higher octave of Afghan oh if
you take the every October webcam is
essentially double in frequency doubling
in frequency so they get bigger and
bigger if you view it as a linear scale
but we perceive it as a kind of
continuous thing so really our
perception is logarithmic in some ways
ok so the start one of the most under
representations used in speech
recognition is Mel frequency kept strong
coefficients and you can use them also
to mobile sort of music so the idea is
that you take your short-time fourier
transform and then you take the bins of
the fourier transform and you group them
into relatively larger bands and these
bands are overlapping and what happens
is that there are 13 min early space
filters followed by 27 log space
builders so for the linear filter this
is the relation between the center
frequency and the boundaries of these
triangles for the logarithmic space
frequency these are the relations so
basically the triangles remain the same
and then they start spreading out and
spreading out so that's the stage of
mill filtering and that is supposed to
model essentially how the human ear
works so you have sort of this
relatively good approximation of how the
human your perceive different stuff yeah
correct so this is this is yeah this is
more an implementation efficiency in the
sense that it's much faster to compute
short time for your transfers and for
the signals of interest you typically
can come up with a decent time
resolution so in both the case of speech
or go missing and music recognition it
turns out that that is actually ok and
you use short segments like 20
milliseconds and kind of work there are
some interesting approaches of not doing
that but I don't have time to talk about
them then the next step is this
relatively weird step that I'm not going
to explain too much of taking the log
and that's what's called a gap strong
coefficient and what that does is
essentially tries to be coupled if you
think of the sound as a source filter
tries to make the source part and the
filter part separated and you can think
of that as in in frequency domain if you
have a source filter model it will be
it's a convolution in time domain
multiplication and frequency domain by
taking the log multiplying two things
you make them son so the relation
becomes additive which is a little bit
easier to deal with and finally you take
a discrete cosine transform that is just
used for packing the energy all the
coefficients in the first q coefficients
or the DCP so then out comes the smell
frequency capture all coefficients which
would be 40 numbers if you used all of
them but it turns out if you use the
thin first numbers you get most of the
information you need so you can keep 10
or 13 depends on the application so
that's all a relatively standard stuff
one little side note here that's kind of
interesting is I did this work in
simultaneous it's one of those nights
cases that you you know means someone
randomly at the conference and you have
done exactly the same thing sit down but
anyway I like us 2,000 the idea is that
audio compression works essentially by
having some kind of analysis filter bank
then you get your filter bank outputs
and you have a specific budget of how
many
you can use for every sort of band of
that filter Bank model now by quantizing
these bands with your available bits you
introduce distortion to your signal so
the idea is that can you hide that
distortion and there's by looking at the
characteristics of the year and masking
which is something I don't have time to
talk about basically you can hide the
effect of that distortion so that it's
inaudible so you don't hear it so
basically what out what comes out of the
mp3 compression is essentially
amplitudes for each of those analysis
done so what you can do is a relatively
straightforward idea you can just take
that as your spectrum representation and
then compute a bunch of numbers like we
did that's your feature vector and then
see how well it does and what I did in
the paper is compared that approach with
using directly a short-time fourier
transform or some other audio based
approach so the advantage of that is
that if you do that this work that's
done at encoding time which is already
there for free can be used for your
analysis so rather than the compressing
the audio and then run in your audio
analysis you can do your audience's
while you decompress the audio and that
sort of takes part of this sort of
design constraint or perceptual audio
coding that it's a relatively slow and
painful encoding process and it's a
match faster decoding process so what
you do is you take advantage of all this
work done here to do feature analysis so
it's compress the main feature
extraction which is something that video
people have also been doing so summary
of timber texture features you can you
have some type of time frequency
analysis you use signal processing tools
like the short-time fourier transform or
the discrete wavelet transform and also
percent more perceptually based
approaches like em FCC's there is one
final step that's really important for
texture is that you don't look only at
short-term windows you look at a little
bit larger windows so maybe this window
will be about one second whereas each
line of this spec program would be 20
milliseconds so you can think of this
has 14 lines of your spectrogram and you
compute means and variances of your
features over that texture window so the
reason is that music is relatively more
long term from speech and you want to
capture this statistical quality of how
this kind of image is different than
this image rather than just the short in
quality and if you do an experiment like
just computing these features and
classifying let's say classical music
versus rock music and you just play this
trick of adjusting the size of this
window you will see that you get
significant increases like ten or
fifteen percent improvements in
classification accuracy just by
increasing that size up to a certain
level in capturing the texture of that
sound so what are these features good
for well they're relatively good for
telling apart let's say classical music
from rock music because the frequency
characteristics and stuff are just so
different and sort of the statistical
characteristics they capture a little
bit of rhythm in the sense of the the
variance of that those features within
that window capture some aspects of
rhythm but they don't model it directly
ok so now modeling directly rhythm
rhythm is movement in time it has
origins in 43 so it's the sequence of
accents in poetry there is a one a sort
of the easiest characteristic of rhythm
that most people can understand his
temple the easiest definition of Temple
though its total problematic is a
foot-tapping definition so if I play a
song and you tap your foot with it the
frequency of that tapping is what we
call temples and music now some of you
might tap it twice as fast or whatever
but throw on some level that's a good
definition so in a more complex way to
view rhythm that it's a year article
semi periodic structure over the music
one interesting aspect is that rhythm is
linked to motion so if you look at sort
of what are the frequencies used in
rhythmic events they're the frequencies
we can hit things or strike things or
move our arms if you make something too
fast there is a certain phone
that if you increase the speed enough
nobody even you know rave partiers can
dance anymore because it's just too fast
and same thing with too slow so there
are certain range of frequencies that
are interesting so one thing that
wavelets are really good for is time
having relatively accurate time domain
analysis so wavelets are interesting
because they have been very successful
in image processing they haven't been as
successful in audio processing and part
of the reason is the emphasis that
people have on quad coding and
compression so for coding and
compression of images wavelets work
really well for coding of audio they
don't work so well mainly because audio
is much more sensitive to face
information and wavelets are not as good
as that in that respect but if you're
doing analysis they're perfectly good
tool and this is something I can show
you this is a drum loop so drum loops
are used by DJ's and you know people
like that they're just cleaned wrong
signals so here's how it sounds so so
then you can look at a wavelet transform
so this is a low frequency band of the
wavelet transform it's a little bit more
processing and this is a high frequency
band of the wavelet transform and even
visually you can see it separates the
bass drum from the other stuff so here
is the sound now it doesn't sound as
good as the bass drum but as in terms of
detecting the events it works really
well here is the thigh stuff so yeah
yeah well with a little bit of tweaking
but pretty much straightforward you've
got you know if you use a discrete
wavelet transform you have got sample
things like that so here's a method of
rhythm analysis
I propose it's similar to other methods
but it's slightly different and it's
based on self similarity so you separate
the balance of the signal you calculate
self similarity in each band and then
you fellow compute so we'll go over it
so you start with a discrete wavelet
transform you I extract these outputs
now if you have music these outputs will
not be clean percussive signals will be
notes so you have to do an envelope
extraction stage so you don't capture
the frequencies you actually capture the
events so you do an envelope extraction
and you get these envelopes then you
normalize these envelopes then you sign
them what will happen when you send them
is that envelopes that are this similar
inning face with enhance each other
envelopes that are less similar or out
of phase will kind of destructively
interfere with each other so if you then
take the summation signal in run
autocorrelation what you get is the
peaks of your auto correlation function
are the various periodicity so here you
see there is one for your destiny that's
that one there is one participe that's a
longer one this will be those two peaks
and again I apologize for my drawing
then what you can do so you do that at
relatively short windows every three
seconds you select those Peaks with peak
taking and then you accumulate those
peaks in what I call a beat histogram so
this program is really a histogram of
what are the different very old isset
ease in your sound so if you were you
know thinking of a piece of music it
would be the quarter notes the half
notes the full notes what are the main
repetition elements here's another
example of how it sounds
this is your input this is the low
frequency again you have some aliasing
or whatnot but you don't care you're
doing analysis so this is a heist so
here is what is the output of a beat
histogram and this is a representation
of the fall song so if you have a piece
of classical music that doesn't have a
very strong sense of you know very
regular rhythm so it might have a pulse
it might have other but it's not a very
clear toward icity you get a relatively
flat histogram so the y-axis is beats
per minute the sorry the eggs eggs eggs
is the y-axis is essentially need
strength or how much self-similar the
signal is so if you have a hip-hop
signal you see this clear thing here at
about 90 beats per minute that will play
these examples as we come spirit so if
you try to tap your foot with this
example you will find it not very
you know not the strongest sense of
radiography you can have and here is a
very very strong example if you can tap
your foot with this one trouble so this
is about 19 something beats per minute
here you see that's the double of that
install for one thing if you think of
two pieces of music a piece of country
music at 80 beats per minute in a piece
of hip-hop at 80 beats per minute what
will happen is this peak in a hip-hop
will be much larger because it's much
more self similar so there are a couple
of features that I want to point out one
is that by this representation you
capture a couple of different things
about rhythm you capture the temple you
can sir how strong the sense of
templates so this beat strength actually
I don't have time to talk about it but I
did a user study and it's actually
something that people perceive
consistently if you ask people to sort
pieces of music by beat strength they do
it very reliably and pieces that are at
the same temple so it is a valid kind of
thing the other one of the biggest and
this is a nice little trick that I love
to talk about is that frequently people
when they do analysis we have this
tendency to always try to come up with a
perfect solution so people have been
fighting to get really good beat
detection for ages whereas the most
important information is that the
failure of your BT vector so if you're
looking at characterizing pieces of
music as you can see pretty much you can
come up with a rule if your histogram is
relatively flat it's plastic out if it's
not flat it's royal for pop or some sort
of that so just wrapping around your
failure and in making it information is
an interesting trick and as long as you
are using machine learning even
imperfect information can feed it to
your system and improve it okay multiple
fits detection I don't have that much
time to go over this but basically it's
a it's a paper published by tolonen and
Caroline and it's an engineering
simplification of a perceptual
detector so it's basically something
that outputs similar results to what
people who model the human ear do but
works much more efficiently it basically
separates the signal into two bands
above 1 kilohertz and below 1 kilohertz
the one below is directly detected for
periodicity the both one is low pass
filtered and half wave rectified sits
Northern envelope approach the two
periodicity detections our son then
there is this summary autocorrelation
that removes the effect of harmonics and
essentially what you get in the end is a
histogram of pitch candidates so it's
it's basically how many sees how many
jeez how many E's you had over your
whole song now obviously this will make
a lot of errors but statistically over
the whole song it will get some
information so this type of information
is useful for example country music has
fewer chord changes than jazz music so
sort of the jazz piece will have a more
diverse histogram with more pitches
whereas the country music will only have
pitches at the main court so you can use
that type of information for those of
you who are in music theory you can do
this little neat trick here of
converting this program that's chromatic
into a circle of fifths and that has
certain properties in the sense that
things that are closing the circle of
fifths are closed harmonically and and
that is important if you know music
theory which I don't have time to
explain one thing that's a little
important note is that pitch is very
similar to rhythm only at higher
frequencies so if I start tapping this
thing here you're hearing discrete
events if I start hopping at too fast
and I could continue that we still hear
discrete events but if I could make my
spin really fast if I had superhuman
muscles if I will Superman I could get a
continuous sound the fact that we hear a
continuous sound is a total perceptual
thing there is nothing in the signal the
signal could be continuously getting
closer and closer and at one point there
is a threshold where we say this is one
thing
it has to do with perception the fact
that if something is emitting regular
sounds at that frequency it's probably
coming from the same source so I might
as well perceive it as the same source
so here is a this example I'm not
Superman but I can program so here's the
same example in code now if I I don't
have a plot of the signal but it's
exactly the same grains getting shorter
and shorter shorter so that's one thing
that's important is there's not much
difference between pitch detection and
rhythm detection only they are done at
different frequencies in so the rhythm
is done at envelopes pitch detection is
done at signals okay I'm not going to
talk about this too much but one thing
you can do is for those of you for
musicals you can take your FFP and grew
call the octaves together so anything
that spaceman octave apart gets folded
into one thing so it's the same thing as
what people who have done 20th century
music called pitch class and you get
what's called a chroma based
representation so if you had something
like this originally you get something
like this this is a singer and it's
basically collapsing the fact that all
cuffs are perceived in the similar way
to make up all the Seas in one kind of
bin and all the piece in 1 bid and it's
very similar to the pitch this program
is just a different way of calculating
it rather than extracting individual
pitches if they call the energy and
group it into those bins okay one quick
example actually I won't have time to
play this audio example so if you are
interested maybe in the end of the talk
if anyone is interested is to look at
how these individual features affect
things so here I have a query and I will
I would play the one with just a timbrel
texture the one with the rhythm and one
using the full feature set but what you
can do is you can do a user's body where
you play the results you have users rank
how good they are and compare the
results and this is the feature
performance so this would be random kind
of thing this is by adding texture by
adding rhythm and by using the full data
set so you
you see you get these increases it's
just it doesn't matter the details of
how this graph was done is irrelevant
what I'm trying to say is that adding
these extra features that capture music
specific aspects does give you an
important improvement over just taking
your standard speech recognition front
end and feeding it into a music class
fire so having a domain-specific
approach that skel it's not solves
everything that does help so as I
mentioned John similarity retrieve all
this card to evaluate you have to do
extensive user studies so another
approach that you can do is to do
automatic musical genre classification
now generous are interesting because
they're really labels that are created
by humans there is no official committee
that says what's wrong or what's jazz
but they do have statistical properties
of the type that we have been modeling
that can be used to describe them so
they are what I you know when I give a
talk to I don't know certain groups of
people I say that it's used to structure
audio collection but really from a
research perspective general
classification is a great way without
doing extensive user studies to evaluate
music content features so if you have a
set of features and they do well a
general classification or better than
another set of features well probably
the one that that's better somehow
capture something more about what we
perceive as content in music so approach
is standard statistical supervised
learning you have your labeled samples
your unlabeled samples you try to find
the probability of what's the
probability of a certain sample that
save in speech and it's an unknown
sample using Bayes rule you can convert
it essentially and the name of the game
becomes to escalate this quantity which
is a probability density function of
that what is given a particular class so
what's the prob what's the probability
and escalating this probability density
function is at the core of a lot of
machine learning
hoods so for example one thing you can
say is well I assume that this is a
Gaussian distribution and then the name
of the game is how can you estimate the
means and the covariance matrix from
your samples which is a very simple
procedure relatively more complicated
procedures if you have a gaussian
mixture model then you have to estimate
waits for the mixer the means for every
major component and the covariance for
every make sure component but again all
this is standard machine learning better
classification you can use support
vector machines you can use neural
networks whatever is your favorite this
is not nothing you know it's used in
every field so here are some results I
want to so this is a first of all I want
to start with this study which was done
with 52 subjects by a musicologist it
was called scan the dial so the idea was
how long do you need to hear the music
before you know what generators and
switch the radio station so if I you
know if I Kate rap music how long do I
have to stay on a radio station before I
scan for a different one so one
interesting result I won't have time to
demo it is that with one fourth of a
second you do forty percent on a 10
genera this is 10 jaundice so chance
would be ten percent so you are doing
four times better than chance with only
one fourth of a second now I don't know
how much you know you can Lorelei's one
fourth of a second but it's a really
short lip of sound it's not at all lots
of information you have no rhythm it's
just kind of this grungy texture and you
already get the forty percent way then
you increase the amount of time and then
at about 30 seconds you peak to seventy
percent and then if you use more than
three seconds you don't get any better
like all the information you need at
least four genre is enough three seconds
is enough to capture more most of it so
the rest thirty percent that is
remaining here is just subject
disagreement of what a particular genres
so that's important to understand that
one hundred percent general
classification is impossible to
even by humans so it's not you know it's
not realistic to hope for that this is a
results on a different collection it's
the same number of generous but it's not
the same collection so they are not
directly comparable so even though it
seems like I'm doing the same
performance this is not you suggest an
indication so you get ten percent by
random classification then in my initial
published paper I had a sixty percent
using Gaussian mixture models later I
did a paper with someone else who use
support vector machines so for those of
you who are fans or support vector
machines they actually do that work
better at least in this particular case
we can gain about ten percent yeah
exactly yeah that's about thirty percent
actually I will quantify this a little
bit more so in yep oh this is actually
yeah that's a very good question this is
based on 30 second clips so in a way
this results are slightly unfair in the
sense that it's used it uses more data
than this site so if you actually use
only three seconds these guys go
slightly lower and to tell you the truth
I haven't done it in a real like some of
the features i assume relatively a 30
second clip and I didn't do Mike the
best job I could do to get three seconds
the only thing is that even if you use
30 seconds here you still get seventy
percent so it's sort of okay so now the
important thing is this is how most
people do general classification is they
take the labels off amazon or take the
labels themselves or whatever and get
these results now that's all good and
it's a good way to publish but if you
really want to be do the right thing the
right thing is a hard thing which is to
do a user study so it's not as hard as
this user
that even i just found this randomly on
the web pretty cool so this is work I
did with some people at the University
of dense actually I didn't do much of it
they just used some of my stuff and then
contacted me it was really great work so
what they did is they took subjects 27
human listeners and they took a
collection of 160 tracks and then here
is a histogram which shows a basically
number of tracks that how many like
basically the spells at 27 out of 27
agreed on 20 tracks that they are the
same genre so for 20 tracks everyone
agreed so this is basically number of
tracks this is how many subjects agreed
on their definition so as you can see
for a fair number of tracks people had
quite a bit of disagreement like 10
people thought something 10 people
suffered something else so what you can
do is take the ground truth so what you
say my ground truth is what the majority
of human subjects say a particular track
is so if I have 27 users and 20 of them
say it's rock then I use that as ground
truth and then take the human accuracy
you have arranged from about fifty seven
percent 286 so what that means is there
are certain users that are really agree
with the average kind of consensus and
some of them that completely disagree
yeah so that's that that is something
here are the labels that were used in
this study so obviously other is going
to be a problematic category so but at
least this gives you a certain kind of
range of indication so you get an
average of about seventy six percent
agreement which is approximately the
same as the previous user study on a
completely different sets
that's good then if you take only the
reliable one so if you threshold your
ground through through 18 volts rather
than majority then you get slightly
better results and here is how it
compares with the automatic so this is
random this is automatic and this is the
average human and these are the arrow
bars so as you can see basically the
computer is approximately equal to the
worst human user now these results were
done without using support vector
machine so maybe you could get a slight
boost on that using a little bit more
you know fancier classifier but it shows
that we are sort of okay I mean you know
you it's definitely there's a lot of
room for improvement but what I really
like with these results is that they
really compare it with the right ground
truth comparing it with arbitrarily
chosen labels and even worse labels
chosen by the researcher is always sort
of suspicious okay I I've shown this
demo so many times that I'm sick of it
so I'm only going to describe it but it
does this live real-time display these
bars go up and down radio comes in or
whatever and they just go up and down
and you see them going up and down in
route looks really cool you have to take
my word for it audio segmentation this
is I wanted to show this because it's
work I did on news classification so
even though it's not as interesting as
music i do do some more serious work so
here's a news clip
so that's this part the last great
explorer Jacques Cousteau has died Paris
at age 87 portable Iran is being clear
okay so as you can see just by looking
at the spectrogram if you have an audio
editor you could easily tell that
there's a change from music to to the
speaker here it's really hard if you
have taken the MIT class and reading
spectrograms maybe you can tell that
this is a different speaker than this
one a normal human beings don't so they
would like an algorithm that would label
these parts automatically so the idea of
audio segmentation is to only detect the
changes in the texture not to tell that
this is a male speaker or this is a
female speaker or this is a saxophone
solo only say oh the texture that was
here has changed significantly so there
is a boundary so it's a way to break up
your audio and kind of interesting
chunks so this is words the following
way you take the idea is very simple if
you think of your feature vector as a
ball that moves around in space as long
as it's in one texture it will be moving
in one region of the space and when it
jumped when there is a new texture it
will jump to another region of the space
and move relatively homogeneous Lee so
what you want to detect is these gaps at
the feature vector trajectory so what
you can do is you can take the
difference between successive feature
vectors you can normalize it using a
Mahalanobis distance so that u equal
eyes the contribution of each feature
and take care of dynamic range and
correlations and then you can take the
derivative for this different signal and
the peaks of that derivative signal are
going to be correspond to texture
changes so if you just do pick picking
on that then you get those boundaries so
I'm not going to talk about detail but
it works relatively well you know as
most cases sometimes it doesn't but it
does do a decent job and the nice part
of it is you don't need any training
data so this is a completely data-driven
approach you just chop your audio into
meaningful segments now here's an
interesting problem which shows the
importance of choosing the right
representation so since all of you are
musicians almost you know that you
have symbolic representations like
meteors scores are easy to manipulate
but have a relatively flat performance
all your representations are very
expressive because there are some you
know someone playing that they're very
opaque and unstructured like if I have
an audio recording of a same point I
can't say go to measure 40 I have a midi
file of the same sick sinfonie I can do
that so the idea is if I have both can I
align them can I find in the audio where
each event starts now for a monophonic
signal you can imagine that this is
relatively easy well you do some pitch
detection and then you do some
environment the ideas can you do it for
polyphonic audio and the idea is to use
this idea of a similarity matrix which
can be used for a couple of other things
so what you do is you take your feature
vectors so one axis is your feature
vectors over time with time from zero to
the length of the song going this way
and your other axis is also your feature
vectors from time 0 going to that so the
diagonal is basically comparing feature
vectors to move themselves and then here
you have different delay so you compare
each feature vector with delayed
versions of itself so wherever their
periodicity patterns you get these nice
kind of rectangular structures so if you
put a very structure piece of music like
a duck prelude or something like that
that's very very well for me to get
these really nice looking visuals and
it's a really you know you can do it in
MATLAB in about half an hour and it's a
nice way to visualize music so what we
do is a similar thing only here we do it
or with two different pieces so here we
have an audio version of the dovin spiff
symphony which is generated from a midi
file just by running it through a
synthesizer so it sounds pretty crappy
and here we have a real audio recording
these two have very different lengths
like this one I think is seven minutes
this one is about five minutes so there
are very different durations and the
ideas can we find where they match so if
you try to do this matching with them
cici's fails complaining because
obviously the sound of the real
Orchestra and the sound of the crappy
MIDI synthesizer are so different that
it is no way to work but if you use the
right representation either a chrome or
a pitch histogram representation that
captures essentially the chords of the
song or some statistical information
about pitches then you can do it so here
is just some examples this is the audio
from meeting
so it sounds relatively flat here is the
same piece in an audio recording
so here one interesting thing so what
you try to do is essentially find the
diagonal of this matrix now this matrix
is not a self similarity matrix is a
similarity matrix between two different
sequences is a sort of dynamical
programming type approach and you get
this optimal alignment path there's this
interesting thing here which I wanted to
like if you see it you see there's a
little thing it's not very clear in this
slide so the question is what happens
there well it turns out that there's a
noble solo and the MIDI performance just
plays it on time whereas the human
performer slows down very much and plays
it very expressively so here is the
meeting performance and here is the
acoustic one
it still works yeah we did we took this
and converted it to piano and did it and
it still works you can also generate
your chroma directly from the MIDI but
now it worked for this particular
example if you try to do a Beatles song
it doesn't work as well because you have
blow calls it so it's not you know the
solution for the world that okay I'm not
going to have that much time I'm already
running I guess it's okay to go a little
bit over at that point okay so principal
component analysis I'm not going to
explain it I will assume most of you
know what it is it's just a
dimensionality reduction technique the
main point is that it's a dimensionality
reduction techniques that depends on a
correlation matrix and the data that you
calculate that correlation matrix is
important so it's a dimensionality
reduction technique that depends on some
large collection of sort of sample
signals so that's interesting because
for example if you view the same piece
of music and you do pca on that piece of
music based on a collection of jazz
songs or a collection of rock songs you
get a different pc a representation for
those two so the same content can have
different representations which is
important for visualization so this is
just an idea you take your PCA vectors
do some little massaging of them and
convert them to color stripes so this
goes from left to right and what you can
the nice part is that immediately
visually you can see interesting
features so you can see that the first
half looks like this part and the second
half looks like this part and there's a
first part in a second part and you see
that right away rather than having to
listen to you know six or five minutes
of music to determine that so this is
this piece I can't play all of them but
this is just showing the change from one
texture to another
this is relatively fat complex
orchestral picture and here it changes
so what's really interesting is that
this file fear is a waveform that it's
colored with the same process on instead
of having a rectangle I do it over the
waveform it is exactly the same audio
file as this one and the colors are
completely different the sections are
completely different because I used a
different set to do my principal
component analysis so this is principal
component analysis using only the file
itself so it shows more set of relations
within the file in more detailed
information us just a little side note
so I do i do some user interface stuff
in visualization stuff that i don't have
that much time to talk about so i
finished the main part of my top which
is the content based analysis now i'm
going to talk really quickly about some
future challenges and some quick
overview of what i'm doing it so to me
the main challenge is auditory scene
analysis so that's where we are really
severely lighting is if you have
multiple sounds overlapping sparking a
different time some of them are speech
some of them are music some of them are
sound effects how can you deal with that
complex information so issues like
stream formation sound source
identification so saying oh there's a
saxophone playing that's an easier
problem than separating the saxophone so
sound source separation is a harder
problem than some source identification
and it's all related speech recognition
in noisy environments instrumentation
detection so telling there is a drum and
a saxophone playing model-based
instrument tracking so you have a model
of what a saxophone sounds like and you
want to kind of follow it through score
all these are really interesting
problems that to my knowledge no one has
solved even close to satisfactory so
obviously all the topics i covered are
not completely sold but at least we have
made some decent progress this is very
open new area so if you're interested
especially for students these are really
cool topics so some questions that are a
little bit more philosophical to me the
essence of music perception is time
perception more than any other art form
with the exception probably of dance
music plays with our notions of time
what is really interesting about music
that is that all it's a very complex
signal it's very abstract and has very
little external semantics so in speech
recognition you have all this language
huge model riding with you that tells
you that the dog is a mammal and mammals
have four legs and all that knowledge
representation music your semantic model
is much less complicated so in a way you
get some of the benefits of the
complexity without the additional
complexity that complicates your job so
I think that music understanding is key
to understanding the human brain now
thats might be a little bit
controversial claim but i do think that
the reason why do we like music so much
why why are we so different why every
culture in the world likes music and
it's mainly because it plays with our
sense of time human beings have the most
expanded time scales than any other
organism on this planet we can envision
our debt as individual lately we can
envision our death as a species we can
envision our birth we just go on all
these timescales all over the place
short-term timescales long-term time
skills and that's what music is about
it's all about short-term dependencies
long-term dependencies longer turn
dependent so how is one and another more
practical question is how is music going
to change with digital music
distribution so I already asked Cormac
this question which is not not exactly
that one but my question was more
specific if you look at the distribution
of buying songs in itunes is it
different than the distribution of songs
playing in the radio my suspicion is
that it is I think that it's more
diverse worth light than out more
personal more subjective I don't think
everyone is buying britney spears at i
think i don't have the data but that's
my feeling and i have a feeling that no
matter what copyright protection is just
these are all details they're all going
to go away as devices become cheaper and
digital distribution becomes common the
whole way music is produced and
distributed and photo is going to
the same way that writing books change
with the invention of the press the same
way that music changed with the
invention of recording it's just a
complete change and it's just happening
with just it goes too fast that we don't
even realize it okay so quick overview
of my current research and then we are
done this is topics this is the work
that I've done with odd Jacob poor
Peters reason I should mention and it
loves to who is my friend here and algae
has built a sitar that is sort of
enhanced with sensors so there are two
set types of sensors there are sensors
on the threats there is a network of
resistors that detects pitch by sort of
where you press each string and then
there is this dist answer when you place
it are you sort of strong by having your
thumb attached so by looking at the
pressure of the spam you can detect the
upward or downward motion and this is
some sound example of a day playing this
thing
so I do so the idea here which is really
where I came in is that so the idea is
the following that it's clear that some
of that information for example the
downward upward stroke is somehow
encoded in the audio like good if you
have a good ear you can tell it but it's
not a very direct mapping so the idea is
what we do is we use the the sensor to
collect training data and then use
linear regression to build essentially a
virtual sensor a pseudo sensor and we
have a really nice machine learning loop
because we can collect as much training
data as we want and once we have shown
that what our model does as well as the
sensor we just throw it away so it's a
good way to kind of start by having the
sensors and then get an instrument that
is us sort of digital as the sensor
based instrument that doesn't have the
sensors some other projects recently I
just had a paper on query by beatboxing
so beatboxing is where you do a rhythm
with your mouth this is how it sounds
these students are pretty good at it
actually so this is a human consuming
the rhythm with their mouth in and their
sound this is not a john watham another
one so what we can do is we can
detecting the visual bass drum and
hi-hat sounds and then map them to other
sounds like a MIDI sound so you can
create your own drum loops and then we
also did some simple drum loop style
classification so things like there's I
don't know what they mean their job R&B
and i was told that they are different
styles I was actually surprised i did a
user study on myself and i could
reliably identify them even though i
felt that i was randomly picking they
answered oh but it okay and then I I do
a couple of sort of less research like
projects but I think pretty cool
projects with undergrads so I these are
the best students that sort of choose to
do directed studies which is a project
oriented course so one of them didn't
matter
interpreter in SML which is a functional
language so we can you know because the
whole thing you can do nested erase
everything and interpreter for that it's
pretty cool and then this is Eliza for
those of you who know Eliza the sort of
famous AI program for music
recommendations so you will you type
Master is the program so it will ask you
do you like music you like rap music yes
and then you just chat with it and it
just keeps playing and recommending
things and stuff so this is some people
who have used my software this is the
coolest project of all they did a game
where the terrain of the gain is adapted
to the music you are listening to so
this is the sort of flat chilly music
flat brass plains and this is the rocky
stuff so the topography of the island
changes and then some other stuff
doesn't matter so I would like this is
the end this is so some of my
visualization stopped running at the
princeton display wall which is this
huge nice very well not very expensive
but still not something i can have in my
bedroom well but i do hope that one day
I'll you know sit in my bed and all my
room will have you know a galaxy of the
universe pieces I'll be able to say zoom
in the blue section play me something
faster I don't like that song take it
out or send it to the outskirts of the
galaxy and cover all these cool displays
if you're interested in more you can
check my web page and I've been sort of
advertising izmir which is the music
retrieval conference this year in its in
Barcelona which is a really nice place
or if you wanna go it's sometime in
October and there's this sort of central
website for music information retrieval
that has links to all past izmir
conferences music I our mailing list and
online papers and all sorts of goodies
so thank you very much and any questions
or
yeah there are plenty of ways to do
indexing but it's all you know nothing
music specific and in their ways to do
multi dimensional indexing actually for
it's not that bad i mean i just do plain
leather search and it works fast enough
because the feature space is like 30
features for each zone so if i was
scaling to a million songs then you can
do something like in mood logic where I
did all your fingerprinting it's a
pretty sophisticated scheme that you can
do efficient searching but for that I
really care about the features a salon
tolling oh ok yeah so that's fine
colonel oh I didn't mention that but
yeah well it's kind of a similar idea
you just take a bunch of numbers and
actually I have no idea if these are the
best numbers to take it they just kind
of work you pick the fight of the main
peak and the position of the main peak
so that's the tempo and the sort of how
self simulated no it's actually six and
then you do the secondary peak and then
you do their relation so if it's a 24 or
44 or three for one feature that I
haven't explored is the width of those
Peaks if your rhythm is very constant
they will be narrow if you sort of have
the variations in your rhythm they will
spread out but I haven't looked at that
I mean you can see it in plot sometimes
what I haven't sort of put it into the
whole thing and an interesting side note
is you can do the sort of creepy machine
learning approach of throwing the whole
histogram into a support vector machine
which deals well with large feature
spaces and then you do get better
results than if you throw the fourth the
five numbers which somehow means there's
a little bit more information buried in
that thing but I
yeah oh no they are actually they work
better sort of a fine but the point is
you don't like the way I envisioned it
is you will never have any labels if you
have any labels it will be your own that
you will say this is the music I listen
to when I wake up in the morning and you
will train a model that will take on own
songs and put you know with some
probability output whether you will
light them in the morning or not it will
be genres but first in specific and
really I think if you have good browsing
tools not searching by browsing you
music is about finding pieces that you
like it's not like I want if you I don't
want to go find I don't know you're my
favorite song I know what it is I can
just type the name and and hear it it's
it's about exploring so I think that
that's the key and generous are just the
inconvenience like I'm famous in a way
for my general classification paper but
I think it's stupid generous should not
exist you have a good search engine and
a good feature representation and if you
combine it with the other data we were
talking like if you combine it with
collaborative filtering metadata usage
patterns playlist information and sort
of fold it all into one system then you
have a full system name for that the
main goal for me the main is how can you
find music that you never have heard of
that you think is really good that's the
challenge and obviously you know never
listening to kenny g is a very noble
goal
and feel free to email me you know with
any additional stuff Thanks oh okay oh
okay oh man I hope I haven't like you
know you can't email me and i have been
a little bit or anything no I know about
all this okay okay okay yeah I sort of
tried to make it